but basically it's the ability to to
give Engineers the uh the power to bring
the data they need in a click of a
button without kind of the the status
quo how you do it today or how you used
to do it and we're talking about data uh
we're talking about you know as in any
other industry we want to take decisions
uh Based on data uh for engineers this
data is how their application is
behaving logs metrics traces you know
line by line the behavior of the
software that's kind of the the
debugging process or or the uh or the
behavior process of the application
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today I'm so excited to be
speaking to shakal Fogel the CEO of
rookout he spent the last two decades
leading data-driven businesses products
and r d teams from early stage startups
to government organizations Shahar is
passionate about software architecture
and observability as a cyber security
team lead product manager VC investor
and the Cambridge University MBA alumni
thank you very very much for joining me
today and as the CEO of rookout a
problem space that I think I'm
personally very excited about so I'm I'm
excited for this conversation and I'm
excited to learn and understand you know
the way that you're breaking paradigms
and shifting consumer behaviors and sort
of Reinventing a process that that I was
educated as something that um has a
certain way of being and and all of a
sudden roorkout is coming in and
changing and tell me that there's a
different way to to optimize for the
same objective but but in a much cleaner
way your experience doesn't start from
root card youth you have a multitude of
experiences in in different sectors in
different environments
um and right before we'll get into that
I'll ask you to introduce yourself and
and what you're doing with workout I
have to ask how you've experienced uh
Roger Federer's departure because I know
how crazy you are about tennis I know
God that was the like the week of Shiva
for me like it's very very good pressing
you know I'm a big big tennis fan
besides the fact that I'm playing tennis
since I was can't remember when you know
I'm a big big Roger the fan my my dog is
named Roger uh and you know three of my
kids were born in Switzerland so we have
uh you know we have strong bonds but you
know life goes on and uh
hoping someone else will come and take
over him
I don't know if anybody can um if
anybody will be ever able to have the
the Persona he created and I remember
that that image I have it somewhere
printed here at the image of him sitting
next to Nadal and you can see in the
doll's face
anyways
difficult 4am watch for me you know
thank God for the last game of Roger
Luna watching him lose and then watching
the ceremony anyway
unbelievable yeah yeah
um so going back to to you and Luke out
tell me a little bit about your own
Journey leading up to root card just so
that I can get a little bit of a better
perspective on on who you are what
guides you throughout your career
awesome so I started my career first of
all before my career
um I married I have four kids that's
always you know what defies me as a
family person and a family man that's uh
first and foremost uh but besides that I
started my career in the Israeli
intelligence forces like many of my
friends in the ecosystem as a software
engineerist but throughout the decade in
the service doing mainly cyber security
where if there was a software engineer
at timely department head a course
leader I did the many
uh many positions uh back then but that
kind of gave me the the foundations of
what it takes to
to build faster to manage software
engineering and and all of that respect
um afterwards I moved to the UK I did an
MBA in Cambridge University so I lived
for a couple of years uh in Cambridge in
London then I moved to Switzerland or to
Geneva I spent around
seven years I started the principal in
the visible and doing maybe early stage
Investments and uh
stayed around around the Enterprise
soccer early days of SAS uh kind of 10
12 years ago and after a few years of
the VC space that moves back to the the
real world the operational world and I
was a VP product in a couple of European
companies and in Connecticut and bradics
uh mostly around you know some security
some big data analytics uh that sorts
came back to Israel five years ago
enjoyed Rook out three years ago I was a
CEO that's kind of my past 20 22 23
years
working around the tech industry I mean
not just incredible
um Diversified experiences in in the
domains you were in but and not just not
just in the domains not just in the
positions you've held but also in the
the lifestyle that you've LED I mean
very different Lifestyles from from
London Switzerland Tel Aviv you know and
so it sounds like you've you've really
amassed yourself with all these Amazing
Life Experiences if you had to sort of
summarize or dial you know really
distill what you're excited about what
is sort of the Common Thread between all
these different activities all these
different positions that sort of help me
get a better picture of who shops it is
I I think kind of what uh defines me in
my career is that I like to do lots of
things uh and which you know basically
takes technology on one end and some
kind of an impact today you know in the
past they get the business impact before
it was National Security impact that
basically what's the the meaning of
building the stuff that we're building
and and constantly trying to you know to
to find the common ground between the
two uh whether it's product positions or
CEO it's you know dealing with
everything
um but that's kind of how I look at it
you know on a technology on a product on
a business and most importantly on the
people's uh level how how you built a
machine that you know needs to work with
so many uh elements together and and
reach a certain goal at the end of it
wonderful okay got it so take to me take
me to Lookout and um and then let's
start with you know explain to me a
little bit about the problem space that
that you're in because this is a problem
that I've experienced myself quite a bit
but I'm curious to hear how you define
it in your own words and then we'll dive
a little bit deeper into the strategy of
it and what this actually means for the
ecosystem and and a bit about World
Market as well
awesome so so kind of the problem The
Rook up solves every engineer uh relates
to it you know says the beginning of
time even if we talk to ctOS that the
last time that they developed software
was 20 30 years ago they felt the pain
back then now it's even more Amplified
but basically it's the ability to to
give Engineers the uh the power to bring
the data they need in a click of a
button without kind of the the status
quo how you do it today or how you used
to do it and when we're talking about
data uh we'll talk about you know as in
any other industry we want to take
decisions uh Based on data for engineers
this data is how their application is
behaving logs metrics traces you know
line by line the behavior of the
software that's kind of the the
debugging process or or the uh or the
behavioral process of the application
now in up until rockout was formed the
only way to do to understand what's
going on is to add log lines so meaning
writing more code and then releasing a
version of the software study to get the
data back from the the software
understanding if you place it placed it
in the right location if so taking the
decision of what to do it's not you know
the whole iteration uh again and again
and again until you you know you
understand what the hell is going on
um so so that's a very long uh iterative
process cumbersome frustrating for
engineers demotivated
table you know eventually when we look
at Engineers time around 60 70 of the
time is is to solve issues or debug
issues only 30 40 of the time is
actually I would say writing the bugs
but writing the features uh that
delivers values to the organization and
you know we able to shift despair then
we want the engineers to focus on
delivering value and spend less time on
on debugging and and understanding and
fixing issues and this way you know the
what we give them is the ability to take
processes that to take take them 20
minutes or two hours or five days or a
couple of weeks in large organizations
and to do it in a click of a button so a
millisecond you know click that button
get the data you need even for
production so you know eliminating the
bid to reproduce environments replicate
issues in closer environment and you
know doubling down on that especially in
the new world in the cloud native world
where everything is distributed and
containerized and the way it develops
offer today is very different than 5 or
10 or 15 years ago but the the value
problem is only Amplified it's only more
difficult because the software is
further or further away from you
so I'm going to ask a simple question
and say I think about it I just think
it's a pretty fundamental one at that
um and it I'm sure that it doesn't have
a simple answer maybe it does but
you know this is a problem that
everybody has right this is a problem
that we've ex we've been experiencing
for 30 40 years and it hasn't made leaps
and downs right the way that I'm
debugging generally last year was the
same way that I've debugged 15 years ago
when I learned how to code
at least for Me Maybe I I'm not maybe
I'm not up to date but but that's that
was my experience I'm wondering you know
usually especially in Tech when we have
some challenge you know we we solve them
over time especially when enough people
have this pain point every developer
listening to this is gonna acknowledge
yes this is a huge pain point of Mind
what's why hasn't this been resolved
before rookout came or what in other
words what what's stopping from a
solution to Common and have the next
step function here
foreign
so first of all you know it's uh
uh the the plain answer is every you
know big idea was you know the first one
to come you know before that people are
asking you know how did we not have
social networks how do we not have no
even you know in software log before we
used to write to to files uh just the
messages
um so you know there's an evolution in
the world but specifically what we do is
we take and and that's kind of something
that comprises many of our team members
we take something that is very
um relevant to the cyber world of how we
do what we do which is by code
instrumentation very low level work and
apply it to the development world so the
ability to click a button instrument the
code in a light manner without
predefining anything and just getting
the data from that instance is is a
skill set and the way we do it is very
much similar to to how you know cyber
tools are are working so that's kind of
you know uh how Rocco was founded and
and the skill set and mindset that was
ported from the cyber world into the
devtools OR devops world uh it's
difficult it's a very difficult
technological uh problem and a challenge
and you know it took us a while to bring
it to a state where uh it's stable
enough and it doesn't impact security
and it doesn't impact performance and
there's a big motor uh and you know up
until the point where we are today where
you know large Fortune 100 Fortune
10 Enterprises big financial
institutions are trusting us enough to
bring us into their you know both
day-to-day but also production
environments which is kind of where the
magic happens
so if I'm so if every company has its
own you know you know the big the big
challenges that a big obstacles it has
to overcome I can't imagine that go to
market is is the most significant one
here right because and this is something
that they see you know everything we've
done with product LED growth over the
last few years bottom-up approaches from
teams I'm I'm even guessing that is a
core part of the strategy here and how
are you experiencing the market
education and the go to markets at this
at this point
so you measure three parts one is around
uh go to market versus technology and
you know I know many many many great
companies who has great technology go to
market is always stationed uh you know
if you're good enough to execute uh your
ability to to find a prospect to sell
them well and and to get them using uh
it's always a challenge in any domain in
any industry for every product but for
us as well you know we need to uh we
need to get there now two other things
that you mentioned is around Market
education uh that's that's a key
Challenge and what we're trying to
achieve because as you said you know
just didn't exist before workout you
know we have some follow-ons uh
competitors that have copied us and
doing similar stuff uh which is great
you know it shows that there's a real
problem and money is important uh but
you know when you go to engineer and you
show them what we do there's always like
the jaw dropping aha how did it not
exist until now uh which means that
people are not actively searching for a
solution like that because they don't
know it exists so we need to educate the
market that you know the solution exists
for them to use it now in terms of kind
of the go to market strategy it's it's a
combination It's a combination of you
know bottom up product LED growth uh
momentum of course that's kind of how
Engineers operates and work and working
but on the flip side you know our our
aim is to sell to large organizations
that's where
um you know the large accounts are
that's where the pain is more
significant both in terms of uh mctr
main factor resolution and fixing
customer issues the impact of something
not working for uh for an Enterprise is
can be hundreds of thousands of dollars
or millions of dollars for every minute
hour day that is not working compared to
a startup which is smaller or smaller
Enterprises uh and and these
organizations Works uh slightly
different you know there is also kind of
plg and bottom-up momentum but but
eventually our solution is that agent
which is going and sitting in production
in data sensitive environment and the
individual engineer it's very difficult
for him to go into uh you know one of
the top three banks in the US and put an
agent did production for their trading
system just doesn't happen so so you
have to go through the process anyways
so no it's a combination
so take me
um you know three five years down the
line what what is what does rookow to
represent in the world what is the
vision that you see for Rook out here
so so basically the vision the North
Star for us is you know the world of
observability and we all know it's uh
it's a very hot word or Trend and and
lots of companies but all these
companies are targeted it Ops people
they're just making sure you know on the
infrastructure level health checks uh
CPU around whatever for a workout we
want to lead we are leading want to
continue living the developer first
observability approach you know as part
of the shift left Motion in the world
where Engineers are getting more
accountability responsibility and
ownership of the application they need
to understand what's going on uh without
calling their friend from Ops uh telling
that I give me access here or there or
add me some data
um so you know we want to give Engineers
the tools to understand what's going on
in the click of a button uh and and you
know to be
a part of their day-to-day
tool set you know for everyone you know
people like like you know for me with
back you know 15 years ago when logging
libraries started uh so you know we
integrated them and said how did you
write to log files until now you know
how did we live without that for me five
years from now I want aborigineers to
say how do we live without the ability
uh to uh to instrument the code in a
live manner how do we every time need to
write code add Lots deploy way do this
whole cycle when I could just click
about and get it
that's very very cool and so if you're
looking today at how you're measuring
the success of your of your own product
and considering the circumstances of the
pain point that have led you to the
conviction that this is an interesting
space how what are sort of the the key
Matrix that you really care about and
and when it comes to measuring the
success of a product like the one that
rookout provides what is it about this
the life cycle of an engineer developer
that you are really I guess data driven
about to optimize for so that rookout
really makes a significant difference
are you asking me or my investors
you know for investors for a company
eventually we're a business or a
venture-backed business it's all about
yeah you know how mature people are
paying us to use the product that's
that's a simple answer putting that
aside per second for us uh how we're
measuring it is of course by adoption uh
within the organization so if it's one
years or 20 users and the growth and the
velocity of the expansion uh uh within
the the Enterprise within the
organization
um uh started the engagements and how
how much not only how many users but how
many how much are they using us uh you
know production issues happens not every
day you know if it happens every day
they have a different problem than
workout than they have to deal with it
in terms of quality but you know they're
using us on the day-to-day as for
themselves life cycle so how much are we
embedded into their process uh and you
know we're of course measuring uh break
points and data and everything around
that but at the end of the road when
we're talking to our clients um we want
to see a paradigm shift uh paradigm
shift in the way that Engineers are
working and for us to tell them listen
you know the way that we're working
today both in terms of how we develop
the software and the software
development life cycle and also how we
solve customer issues with rookout you
know it changed the way that the
business is operating uh it's that big
basically sounds big it sounds exciting
and um sounds like you're very
passionate about both the problem space
and the solution on your in your own
journey and Shuffle I really want to
thank you for taking the time and I'm
very sorry about said that um uh we are
all we all are uh I really am
we we live on and uh and uh thank you
again for coming on this is such an
enjoyable one day
thought-provoking a exercise I think
that I directed for myself and so I
really appreciate the time and the
energy best of luck with the lookout and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you it
was a pleasure and thanks for inviting
me